the future belongs to those who learn
more skills and combine them in creative
ways as time evolves there is a vast
difference in business models and
technology in company or market trends
to adapt new technology to face
competitive market and daily challenges
which in return meet both the need of
company standards and market trend
so not only education or a bachelor's
degree or a master's degree in addition
domain specialized skill pays a major
role which provides great career
opportunity and for placements in top
companies towards id
so in case you're thinking to upskill
your skills and get placed in top
companies that you are at the right
place
introducing skill up by simply learn
skill up by simply learn is a free
learning platform which is meaning
focused to help individuals get started
with their skills to up skill to the
industry required standards
with free access to 1000 plus hours of
learning tech skilling programs covering
over 300 plus in-demand skills with
certifications
scale-up programs in simply learn are
designed according to a self-learning
model where learners have access to
on-demand video based content and
learners will have access to other
comprehensive programs by top industry
experts which will enhance their skill
set and advance their careers in various
fields
now let's get started towards the top
trending and industry demand programs in
2022
which industry experts and industry
demands to face the competitive world
and leading technologies
at first we have data analyst
data analysts play a major role in
collecting raw data analyzing those data
and studying data to provide problem
solving techniques and decision making
thus data analytics playing a major role
in the id field has drank out first as
an in-demand skill in industry
to enhance your data analytics skill
introduction to data analytics course by
skillup provides strong foundation for
beginners to work on various real-time
data sets data visualization for better
decision making offering the most
aspects
at second we have java
java is the most used and popular
programming language
we use in our daily lives right from
developing apps and powering games where
most apps are developed using java
ranked as the most in demand skill in it
for a better game whether being a
beginner or an experienced professional
it's always better to have a good skills
in java
so to upskill yourself in java java
training by scale up is designed to
provide solid foundation and work ready
skills in java development
along with knowledge of core java
operators arrays loops methods and
constructors
moving further towards artificial
intelligence
artificial intelligence or ai is the
future and is everywhere today right
from smartphones to self-driving cars ai
is quite stable in industry trends due
to its salient features of accuracy
reliability availability and many more
due to its rapid growth and reliable
technology the need for ai engineering
and engineers ranks as an in-demand
skill in id
so if you want to excel your career as
an ai engineer introduction to
artificial intelligence course by skill
up is the perfect choice composed of
fundamental machine learning and deep
learning
in addition to ai next we have aws
so cloud storage serves as the most
prominent safe and reliable data storage
method
industry is in search of cloud
architects and cloud computing
professionals for data handling a
company by storing data on its retriever
interested in data handling and playing
with data storage getting started with
aws by skillup is the app choice for you
to explore the world like cloud
computing and data handling
at the end we have cyber security in
modern days cyber security is coined out
to be a familiar term to avoid data hack
and data loss by unauthorized access to
one's individual data
securing data plays a major role in id
to safeguard one's confidential and
credentials
so introduction to cyber security by
skillup is the best choice to excel your
cardio in securing data and to provide a
risk-free workspace
courses offered and skill up by
simplyloan are free which needs no
prerequisites or programming knowledge
where an individual gets free access to
contents and material on demand video
contents and a course completion
certificate with a maximum of 11 hours
of self-paced learning methodology
looks interesting then what are you
waiting for click on the link below and
get enrolled in top industry demand
courses and get certified
to explore the world of i.t
professionals
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here